your excellency dr ursula wonderlayan
president of the european commission
your excellency mr hugo astuto
ambassador of the european union to
india dr vibha dhawan director general
terry eu delegates youth representatives
media representatives and terry
colleagues a very good morning to all of
you we are happy to welcome you here in
terry graham at the resource efficient
terry retreat for environment awareness
and training in short retreat
we thank you for taking out the time
to be with us
and we thank the eu delegation for this
opportunity to facilitate this important
interaction
women leadership and youth leadership
are two important pillars driving
sustainable development and climate
action
to that end this interactive session
aims to facilitate a dialogue between an
eminent woman leader her excellency
doctor ursula wonderlayan and the
leaders of tomorrow
are you
first i have the honor to invite dr
vibha dhawan director general terry to
deliver
some welcome remarks dr dhawan herself
symbolizes women leadership in stem and
science and technology dr dhawan the
floor is yours thank you
thank you so much
for your kind words
uh your excellency dr ursula wonderlian
president of the york european
commission
your excellency mr hugo astuto
ambassador of the european union to
india and bhutan
the entire european union delegation the
youth participants
media representatives and monetary
colleagues
it's a great day for us we are so
excited and we are so grateful to your
commission to have considered terry for
this visit so thank you ma'am thank you
so much for being with us
uh this campus as i explained you while
walking to this place
this in a way shows sustainability
itself it's it's a green campus
we developed it we started here way back
in 84 85
and believe me there was not even a
single tree you can say so
and we started and we thought that it
shouldn't be simply that you
start with the construction activities
rather it was how do we preserve
the
contours which are available over here
and i still remember our discussions
with the architect
and in a way coming straight from the
university for me it was something like
it's it's not a great land kind of an
expression
but
he'll talk to us and he'll say let's
develop these water bodies let's do this
thing
and of course i have been here for many
years to see how you can make a barren
piece of land to a lush green forest
kind of a place
and that too with indigenous species
so we haven't got any species it's not
and
you can say the landscaping done on the
basis of what will look beautiful but it
was more on the basis of what will be
more sustainable
and of course all those discussions even
it was that we don't want to attract
monkeys and we don't want too much of
leaf fall and in which weather what
trees will look good and so on
so that way we are very happy that we
are able to develop and rather now when
people come from delhi and gurgaon they
see it's hard to believe that
in this kind of weather you can have
such lush green forest
now
this symbolizes in a way that we don't
just preach we practice
when we talk of sustainability
and this particular building where you
are and i hope you are quite comfortable
it's not its peak summer
but most of the heat most of our energy
needs we meet from photovoltaics and
there is a unique concept of earth here
tunnel
some of you might be aware that
four meters below the earth
the temperature is average temperature
of that region
so delhi has both
cool season as well as summers and
winters
and therefore the average temperature is
in the range of 25 degrees centigrade
and that is what really speaking is best
for
human comfort
so therefore if you take it through
earth ear tunnel
in summers
it loses heat and in winter it gains
heat and gives you a comfortable
environment
so this particular complex it's uh the
training complex
so we bring participants over there you
can see the rooms so they stay there
no air conditioning so you live close to
the nature
and
all of them they go i should say with
the everlasting impression that to be
comfortable doesn't mean that you have
to be energy gusless so you can meet
your uh
comforts with less of energy and you are
much more fresh in the morning than
compared to coming out of an
air-conditioned room
also uh
this particular campus it's zero waste
generation
so the
the water
which we use in the facilities that is
treated and used for irrigation purposes
so therefore we don't generate
any waste
and
let's come to energy efficiency which is
now becoming a top of the town everyone
is talking about that resource
efficiency energy efficiency
and so on
and again
this particular campus in a way shows
you
that energy efficiency can be achieved
with very little change in what you are
doing all your activities
and
we are very grateful to european
commission and while coming here as i
mentioned to you and rather show
how one of my first projects which was
perhaps in 1988 and many of you perhaps
were not even born at that stage but
those trees are there and it was a
project on
tissue culture propagated plants the
best of the strains how they perform in
different locations
so those trees are quite big now
and
madame i must say that we believe that
eu is a norm leader
and an initiator in terms of many of the
innovations
both in realm of policy and technology
terry we are very grateful to you rather
i'll say what we are is also because of
your support of european commission
their belief trust in terry and we
enjoyed your support for many years and
i can also say
that we delivered so the support or the
finances which you got got from european
union
they were well utilized and we could
develop many technologies and
techniques
i'll also like to mention that again
terry is unique because
on one end we work with the grassroot
level workers we have projects where we
work with the rural communities in
uttarakhand
we work with the policy making so
whether it is right now
policy on hydrogen or nano and so on new
technologies so terry colleagues are
part and parcel of developing those
technologies
we are
doing good research i will show you uh
one facility which is uh
terry dicken nanowire technology center
so it's getting into cutting edge
research we do have pilot scale
production facilities
for mycorrhizal production which is you
can say
going towards organic cultivation
and sustainable agriculture that remains
an important component
we again work as i said with communities
and in the field of climate change
adaptation and mitigation
resource efficiency
in sustainable agriculture as well as
in other fields
waste management because whether we are
talking of green energy
or otherwise the electronic waste
the municipal solid waste
so all those ways they are also to be
treated if we believe in circular
economies so terry is
working in all these areas
and if you talk of sustainability
perhaps it would be difficult to say
what is it terry is not working on
because everything is so interrelated
and one of the uniqueness of terry is
that we have experts in different fields
under the same roof we also have
regional centers so that apart from
delhi we also work on problems
which are specific to particular regions
of the country
we have young colleagues over here and
we believe lots
that youth is the future of any country
and we also believe that somewhere
what is said catch them young because
when we talk of green development green
energy
or energy conservation these apart from
technology somewhere i'll say it is also
an attitude so you need to learn
that clean doesn't mean expensive clean
doesn't mean sacrifice on part of you
it is that you can be green you can be
clean and you can enjoy your life in the
most sustainable way so it's a mindset
so for that reason terry has also
invested
in establishing a deemed university
terry school of advanced studies which
is a research university so we i'd say
postgraduate as well as phd students
so we have close to 800 students over
here over there
so just to it's more of that the kind of
research by involving youngsters we are
doing
we also believe that
the whatever we do that message must go
out
and for that reason we involve with
students at all stages
we have these school students with which
you will be interacting with them later
we also do a annual summit world
sustainable development summit and
my colleague shelly she has done
wonderful job this year in spite of
being a pandemic here and we couldn't do
in person so it was done in a virtual
mode and we have done 20 uh this long
journey of 21 years continuously it's an
annual event
which is attended by almost 5 000
people each year
so and we get nobel laureates
and we do nobel laureates and
policy makers and i extend welcome to
you
to come to that summit physically
it will be an honor for us ma'am
now as shelly mentioned that woman
leadership is crucial
for inclusive and environmentally
sensitive decision making
in political economic and public life
engaging with young people on matters
concerning security
climate change and public policy is
important to promote young leadership
along the global citizens for our common
future
we are extremely honored and delighted
that this intergenerational dialogue
is taking place involving a prominent
woman leader
and our future generation
and we have many young
students over here who are working in
the field of sustainability
they are eager to ask you questions but
most importantly listen to her
excellency for her insights and
comments
so before we move on
on the discussion and the tour
we would like to share a terry
publication on gandhi and the
environment
to show our appreciation for your visit
so this is the book mahatma gandhi
very much thank you
thank you thank you thank you
thank you
thank you so much dr dhawan
i now have the pleasure to invite her
excellency dr ursula wonderland to
deliver a few words of inspiration
before we start the youth interaction
but firstly dr wonderlian has shattered
many glass ceilings to name a few as the
first woman defense minister of germany
and then as the first woman president of
the european commission your excellency
the floor is yours thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much for having me here
dr dawan thank you very much
for
inviting me to terry
indeed there is a long-standing
cooperation between the european union
and terry
to the benefit of the two of us that's
true and many many projects we've done
together
many successes in research and
development we've had together
so it's wonderful for me to be here
and to see for the very first time what
terry is
in in real life
we share
the same concern
and that is the concern
for
our climate our planet
nature around us
the environment we're living in
and if i look at you the young people
you have
you're approximately the age of my
children
i have a very clear idea
what your worries are but also what the
opportunities are
because we all know that climate change
is solely man-made
so it's us
but this also gives us the opportunity
if it's us
and
it's critical right now
it's bad the development right now what
climate is concerned it's up to us to
change something we can do something
about it
this is the problem the difficulty but
it's also the opportunity and i think
terry
is living
what the opportunities are that we work
together on looking at the
root causes
for climate change we know them
it's basically co2 emissions
and the change in biodiversity or the
loss of biodiversity
but with that to look also into the
opportunity it brings along to do
something about it to change it to the
better we can do something we can fix it
and this is our common vision
in the european union as you might know
we have with my mandate developed the
european green deal
which says basically
um we have one chance and that is cut
emissions
go into renewable energies clean green
renewable energies
limit waste
look into the circular economy
and we are deeply convinced
that this is our new growth model
so we are aware
that there are demands out there there
are people who want to
benefit that energy consumption will
increase for example
but we can do it in a way
that it is good for our environment good
for our climate and it's of benefit for
us
and therefore i think india and the
european union have a lot in common
um i've looked at your goals to have 50
of energy coming from renewables in 2030
this is a very ambitious goal
congratulations to that
we share the idea that we really have to
look into solar energy wind energy
biomass hydro power
green hydrogen a big topic
geothermal
so these are the ingredients for success
for success for the economy
for success and benefit for the people
and of course protection
of our climate and our environment
and therefore
protecting
the environment protecting
the climate has a lot to do
with innovation
this is also what we have in common
with innovation big time i'm deeply
convinced that our world either takes
the
right direction
in cutting emissions and protecting the
environment but then we will need clean
innovative technologies that's what
we're looking into
and if the world does that the demand
for these technologies will be enormous
therefore it's such a business case and
business opportunity
for do this to for doing this
development research in innovation into
clean technologies
the other side the or if we don't do it
i don't have to tell you anything about
it
i've read that the month of march
was the hottest here in india
since the last
122 years
and
we also have the experience of the huge
damage of climate change with horrible
floodings deadly floodings
last summer in europe
hurricanes in a region where we never
ever ever had this in the european union
but also droughts wildfires and i think
i tell you something which is familiar
to you
so
we are aware of the risks of climate
change
but we take it in a way that we say we
answer with innovation
we answer with smart ideas we answer
with renewables our answer is the
circular economy
and therefore i'm very much looking
forward to listen to you
but also and this is the reason why i'm
here in india
because i think there's a lot of
untapped potential
between the european union and india we
have a lot in common
and joining forces we can do so much
together to the benefit for our people
but also to the benefit for our our
climate and our planet and therefore
very happy thank you very much for
having me here to answer your question
and to go into a dialogue with you
[Applause]
thank you your excellency i now invite
dr libline carlon who leads the youth
activities at terry to moderate the
interaction between president lane and
the youth representatives lively the
floor is here
thank you shelley
very good morning madam president
just to set the pace for the next
moderation session i would like to
summit that what you have just mentioned
that here is an opportunity for us to
dream big and do good for the
environment i think the answer is right
in front of us we have with us a group
of students who are innovators design
thinkers
gender and social experts
artificial intelligence
practitioners and development
practitioners so it was very difficult
for us to zero down on this group but we
looked into our experiments and projects
with eu we have been successfully doing
a youth climate conclave then they were
students from the erasmus foundation
and we have them all here with you and
they have their bunch of questions and
interactions
so uh how we designed the questions was
we left it to them to raise the main
issues and then they decided what are
their priorities and they're going to
put forward to you so with your
permission madam president we move to
the first question
um
okay
so
greetings madam president i am yash i am
a student of biotechnology and i am a
co-founder of green coalition youth
initiative
so
as we all know covet 19 has highlighted
an imperative for global cooperation
um
so uh the as the covet 19 has
highlighted a cooperation for a global
cooperation for uh
handling the pandemic and other major
issues of similar magnitude so my
question is
will we be able to build back better
uh
especially
without leaving anyone behind
yes thank you very much thank you
you um you are raising a very important
question
um indeed the big crisis looming in the
background is the climate crisis and we
all know
it did not stop it did not sleep while
we were fighting the pandemic the
pandemic is also an enormous crisis with
a lot of
negative
impact on our societies and our
economies
we master
the pandemic
actually basically through innovation
and research and development
i must say
we have developed vaccines effective and
safe active vaccines in record time
it usually takes 10 years and we it took
us one year
we struggled in scaling up the
production of vaccines so we had the
vaccine but scale up the production is
something where i think we take a long
lesson
that we need more pharmaceutical
capacities out there in case that we
have to really scale up the production
of for example life-saving vaccines
but we also learned that
this pandemic
originated
presumably also from
humankind human beings
intrusion in wildlife habitat
and the loss of biodiversity
because
viruses
and also the species of corona viruses
are out there
they are out there in nature
in wildlife
but
the jump
from wildlife to the human beings
only happens
if we're getting too close too deep into
wildlife habitat
so it boils down or comes back to the
big question we're working on together
to protect protect and
maintain
wildlife habitat
and the biodiversity
and therefore it's the answer
to the pandemic is very close to the
topic that we are working on together
now
uh what are we doing besides fighting
the pandemic with of course vaccines and
vaccination strategies
and uh the the behavioral strategies
that we have developed during the
pandemic
we know that we need massive investment
and on the european side we developed
global gateway 300 billion of investment
abroad outside the european union
for the investment needs but we link the
investment
to priorities
and for us the first priority for the
investment
is the green deal
so if you want to invest massively
abroad all over the world in specific
projects
they have not only to do no harm
but to pay off
for the green deal
for example in infrastructure for green
hydrogen
or other renewable technologies
so
by investing in infrastructure needs
increased energy for example
that is necessary we are very clear that
it is up of utmost important that it
pays off not only
um for for example digitalization or
resilience
but also for the green deal
in our investment and therefore you link
in the cure
with the investment
you link
the fight against climate change with a
fight against the pandemic because we
understand in the wider context that
both also are linked
and
as you speak about the green deal here
we have all of you for youth for the
greener future so i think we have met
the right point here and the future will
definitely bring you more closer to
technologies to ideas to
ideas that will actually be the future
of all of you so over to the next
question you would like
good morning madam president esteemed
guests uh i speak for all the youth
representatives here that is a great
honor to be in your presence today my
name is manali bal i am a student of
masters in climate science and policy
from terry school of advanced studies
being students of climate science and
policy are studies and a research lies
in the intersection of scientific as
well as policy issues surrounding
climate change
so my question for you madam president
is that do you think that the impacts of
climate change need to be seen through a
social lens thank you
absolutely thank you for raising this
question there will not be a green
transition if it is not a just
transition
and this includes the social angle
the social lens as you said
to see it through the social lens
because
we need to change for the better
the way
we produce the way we consume the way we
behave we need to change for the better
we all know that
and if i look for example at the
topic of renewable energy use of
renewable energy
we know that households that are
vulnerable households with very small
income it will be very hard for them to
invest
to have access to renewable energies
not to rely on the old dirty fossil fuel
energies but to move forward to the
modern technologies the clean
technologies but this needs investment
this is impossible for vulnerable
households
they have no
leeway no room to maneuver financially
so there you need to support financially
it's in our societal interest because of
the protection of the climate because
these modern clean technologies are
better
but also because
we do not want to leave anybody behind
this
subsidies or the support of the
vulnerable households or small
businesses for example is necessary
how are we doing this in the european
union i give you an example
you are familiar of course with the
emission trading system
so that we say those who pollute the air
with co2 have to pay a price
on emission of sui co2 because our
nature cannot pay the price anymore
this is on one hand the price on
emitting co2 on the other hand it nudges
the companies to say oh this is
expensive if i emit co2 i have to pay
for it why don't i look for a cleaner
technology and move towards that one i
avoid the payment
for the emission trading system
those who emits you too
have to pay this brings revenues
and you can use these revenues for two
things
one is
innovation
for clean technologies but the other one
is
subsidies for the vulnerable households
subsidies for the small businesses that
they can adapt
to the modern clean technologies
this is the way where how it has to go
and therefore thank you very much for
your question because as i said there
will not be a green transition if it's
not a just transition and if we don't
leave anybody behind
again like what i really liked in your
question was
in spite or i would say along with being
a student of science you have a keen
interest in social issues and that is
where the focus of interdisciplinary
studies
plays a role and i'm really happy that
all of you even our interactions with
you brought out all the different
aspects of sustainable development that
students need to be concerned about be
it the social be the cultural be the
economic and the environment and all of
you are definitely going to be
ecopreneurs very sure and remember
innovations are going to be the key so
over to the next question
thank you
warm greetings to everyone present and
her excellency madam president it's an
honor to be in your presence an
inspiration like you and it's delighted
to have you here in our country welcome
i am anshul gotham i am a student
currently pursuing bachelors in
technology in biochemical engineering
like you mentioned biomass bioenergy
being in a country like india where
agriculture is an integral part of our
legacy
this field could really bring a lot of
um there could be a long path it could
bring a lot of light on climate change
so i am studying that only currently
now um
my question to you is that yes as
individuals we all work towards climate
change in one way or another but as a
whole youth
what can we do what could be our
contribution with respect to the
adaptation and mitigation strategies
with respect to climate change of course
so what can the youth do with respect to
this you can do a lot
and we need you
absolutely indeed uh because you can do
a lot first of all you raised your voice
and you raise your voice
so friday's for future but in any other
also environmental activity it's so
important
because it's your future as i said you
have the age of my children my youngest
one is 22 my oldest one 34 so somewhere
in between
they they are
what age is concerned and they are as
worried and intrigued like you are
they see of course what happens with
climate change
and we need you to raise your voice
and to push us hard to move on faster
but we also of course need
your young brilliant minds
to go into research and innovation and
development
and when i listen to you and your
background i know that's exactly what
you're doing
you know that we're just at the
beginning of the changes the positive
changes that come along with all the
innovation that is out there that we
could tap on
and therefore we really need you not
only to be the advocates
of fighting climate change the advocates
of our planet of our nature
but also the ones who develop the
solutions
so we we do need youth
more than ever before thank you so much
ma'am it's a pleasure thank you
now i think we have time for one more
question but i'm sure all of you would
be wanting to ask more so one last
question please from the group who would
like to ask
a very good morning to you madam
president um so my name is nivedita i'm
an interdisciplinary researcher at terry
and my background is international
studies and i'm one of those people who
believe that science is important but so
is the economic structures political
structures and international order so i
know that eu policies are aimed at
reducing the you know environmental and
harmful effects of plastic
and waste and
you know
um to improve eu's uh resource
efficiency so my question is that
how do we ensure and what steps are what
actions are you taking to
uh ensure that the developing world is
also part of the process and they are
not left behind and
you know that they can also play a role
in improving uh and and you know raising
the awareness uh to tackle this plastic
menace
yes thank you very much for that
question it shows the broader context
that whatever we do
we need a global coalition for it
we need to mobilize
all the other forces apart from let's
say india and the european union if i
look at the european union
as a developed country
we emit
only but this is in parenthesis
nine percent of the co2 emissions
but we are completely aware
that if we would lean back
the the
catastrophe that climate change brings
along
if it's unleashed further
would hit us full scale
so um we have understood that it is
important that we lead
uh with the european green deal that we
show that change is positive possible in
a positive way but also that we create
global alliances
and the next cup
27
is important for us for example we have
different
forms of alliances that help us uh to
really not only bring the mindset
forward but also solutions with south
africa for example we have a um a
initiative
we is the european union with other
countries together to support south
south africa to phase out of coal and to
go into the renewables so you need the
global support for developing countries
but they have an enormous amount of
resources there's an abundance for
example here what sun is concerned you
know it
and i mean this is the primary source
for uh solar energy
so to invest in that here and to think
about the smart ways
to not only use the energy here in india
but also to export it that's the task
that we have to tackle together to the
benefit of india but also of course our
climate and others who need this energy
i come from a region where sun is not in
abundance
so
this is amazing to see what the
potential here is and
you were speaking beforehand you were
speaking about the biomass topic
and ud excellency also when on our way
in here
you were speaking about the biomass
topic i was visiting sweden a few weeks
ago
and there i visited a project
where they have district heating for
stockholm
the capital
with biomass it's the undercut of their
vast forest it's just with the leftovers
they use it
they burn it
capture the co2
make sure it is not emitted
but put it store it somewhere else in
caverns under
under the the surface
and with the biomass heating they heat
stockholm in the district heating
and
when they're done with their project
which is already up and running
stockholm will be the first climate
positive
city in the world
so they extract more co2 from uh from
from the atmosphere
than they know use for producing
with the biomass the heating for the
district just as an example because you
were mentioning the biomass
so to learn from others
and to develop technologies that connect
others for example for us the northern
part of africa
has an enormous potential with wind and
solar
to be the sources to produce green
hydrogen to then to bring through
pipelines that we used to have
for gas fossil fuel gas but now in the
future would like to use for green
hydrogen is a typical example
to to show that you need these these
global alliances
at the very end
if you allow
i would mention one sentence because i
heard it over and over again the gender
topic and the being the first woman in
different areas
as i see many young
women and men here in the room
basically
the
the thoughts behind it is women are not
better than men they are different
and if we look at climate change and
we've just touched upon a few topics
where there's a huge potential
in risks and opportunities
if you have different groups to look at
the risks and the opportunities you see
a wider spectrum
because we all know by experience we
have a certain approach to the world so
as an individual i have a certain view
on the risks and the opportunities but i
don't see others
if you
mix the leading teams
you have a much wider view on risks and
potential and opportunities
my second point is
um
this is of course the reconciliation of
family and career
and
my husband and me we have seven children
my husband is a medical doctor
and what we've learned in our life is
if you share
the positive benefit and the burden
among the two of you
you have an enormous amount of strength
that results from that
it is a positive experience for my
husband to be much closer to the
children and have a career it's a
positive experience for me to have a
career and to be close to the children
but if we divide
the work between us so on more shoulders
the benefit is much much higher
and
children
have a right to have a mother they have
a right to have a father
they need other children therefore you
need good child care you need good
schools
that leave the parents the opportunity
to have their career
and after school to have time with the
children and when i speak about parents
i speak about the father who is as
important as the mother
and therefore
you are
a new generation
that has a hell of a lot of tasks ahead
of you
um you are smart brains
i mean brilliant minds
so there's a lot we want of you the
world is asking of you but also a lot
you can given the lot you can develop
and share
and if you keep in mind that working
together be it
at home in the family albeit in your
career
is
scaling up the benefit for all of you
and that you need
different views on risks opportunities
i'm not worried about india's future
thank you so much
we have really learned a lot today and
i'm sure we would have marked a new
chapter in our lives and thank you for
passing forward these messages of
diversity respect for diversity and
inclusion yes that is going to be again
a way ahead for all of us and for the
benefit of all 2022 marks as the eu year
for the youth so look forward to more
interactions more work more power and
more responsibility with this uh thank
you so much ma'am madam president for
your uh
remarks and for your viewpoint on
various aspects put forward by the youth
i would also like to place on record a
special thank you uh to his excellency
ambassador of eu mr hugo estudo thank
you sir for providing us these
opportunities of interaction a special
thank you to dr vibha dhavandiji who
keeps encouraging us and powering us
with more work and with this and thank
you to all our media friends who are
here with us we move forward to the next
part of today's session uh ma'am we have
some outdoor activities and we will be
showing you the way to that and with
that a very very sincere thank you for
your presence today thank you thank you
very much all the students will remain
seated uh while the guests receive okay
thank you so much thank you all the best
yes all the best
stay strong
as we as we are saying normally in in
french we say bonk
so we wish you a lot of strength